my friend Casey Neistat treats his skin
a very unique manner I can fix it
[Music]
definitely broken
bro code early brother sorry is this
some hidden reason behind this some
existential of war game I'm gonna get
code this puzzle I'm gonna get deep into
the mind of a kid to actually understand
all of this I'm talking to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I spend sleepless nights trying to
string together conclusion quite
literally and then it hit me
I'm gonna transform myself into a broken
camera then call my friend Martin is
that what can I do for you man we'll get
into the building
they let me to Casey hey we'll take one
look at my malfunctioning monitor it's a
still broken and toss me aside well way
to be accepted into the group what are
you thinking man
you can't just make noise while he's in
here pull yourself together who are you
I'm Danny bro the animator you're
collaborating with look I I can control
your face what are you doing well when
you told me the idea I realized I've
never really been in casing studio and
you know I thought it was a good idea to
spy on him and learn how his brain works
oh dude not cool not cool oh don't say
guy's name in vain amen for real mack
daddy for real homie how do you know
this [ __ ] you've been here for like 10
minutes chill brother
we are good all right let me introduce
you to the gang the meetings about to
start what meeting
[Music]
so we got the lonely stoner and then me
the leader of this operation wait what
all right quieten down now welcome to
the last meeting first let's open up
with the serenity prayer
[Music]
Jesus Samantha you're never talking
that's what comes out of you moving on
quick question what the [ __ ] is going on
yes over tomorrow morning we execute the
plan
yeah [ __ ] that guy man girls the lights
please
but that's my blue so macdaddy God will
release the swinging bomb that will not
come off his path slipping on a
strategically placed boosted board
Tillie hits his head I'll apply the
brain stricter and then my phone
Gacy will always answer my call which is
only twenty two stairs funded by a
hundred and fifty human steps through
the graveyard to another ninety five
Sol's 160 human footsteps Kuwait
onsen AC on set
JC come on
dude huh stop this right man can't you
see I'm about to take over you too kid
you're [ __ ] crazy breathe
whatever man back to the party let's go
Wow
I guess I'll just hide out here
[Music]
I know of a bunch of degenerates now's
my time
[Applause]
it's time to stop this thing not so fast
buddy boy
quick everyone Casey's coming down get
down bro
dude there was like there were stairs
and there was chanting he knows this
there was a GoPro who is Danny who is
actually me and he was riding away I'm
you gotta lay off the drugs man I
promise you
[Music]
thanks again Marlon
we should end it there yeah I feel like
a cliffhanger is the best place to kind
of leave off here leave leave people
wanting more we've got to find out if
they want more though this is Danny in
real life we are actually friends and
he's what I'd call in South Africa my
boy I'm his boy key you supposed to say
don't call me that
sorry I feel like I've actually got
something to say one known human truth
is that there are two sides to every
story
I believe there are three there is the
objective approach the fly-on-the-wall
viewpoint through the eyes of the artist
a creative way of looking at things
around you and essentially that's what
this YouTube channel is if I come up
with an idea I try and make a film out
of it if it has to be in the medium of
using animation I'll use animation this
is all a process of me growing as a
storyteller and filmmaker and I really
want to just do a whole bunch of
different things so each week there will
be something new something different
something fresh in my mind so yeah I'm
gonna take a leap of faith because this
is such a different kind of video for me
let me know what you thought in the
comments below honestly dude the
building here just nervous stops New
York is like the noisiest place in the
world but annoys you that's that's an
idea for a film next week something to
do with sounds
next week's phone other than that I'll
see you next Wednesday
[Music]